hi I'm Erik Bosse and adventures 4 is
another clue from the directors possibly
hinting at the movie's plot and since we
are Marvel junkies who will grasp at any
precious taste of how infinity war could
resolve let's do what we do best here
and overanalyze the hell out of this
within another new rockstars
we okay Sherlock tweet the Russo
brothers the directors of these movies
tweeted hashtag rapped presumably
meaning that production and shooting for
venture spore has finished pending any
further reshoots or audio redoubling
they could do for the movie and of
course post-production and visual
effects rendering but the big mystery is
this photo what the hell is this a
close-up of something very bright
probably what it looks like when Drax
stares at the Sun for too long but
thanks to the internet lots of wonderful
heroes have tried to enhance this image
running it through various filters to
try to see what it could be let's break
down the possibilities first someone
said this looks kind of like Bucky the
winter soldiers arm from the elbow down
to his wrists I guess I kind of see it
but remember Bucky did receive a new
vibranium arm an infinity war from the
good people of Wakanda and I don't know
why his arm would be glowing in blue and
why the Russos would consider it that
important there are definitely a few
game-changing weapons I could see the
Avengers using Stormbreaker a new shield
for cap Hawkeye's arrow but I just don't
see Bucky's special arm being all that
important but this does lead me to a
second explanation war-machines cannon
the last time the Russos tweeted a
cryptic image it showed Joe Russo on set
with an interesting set piece visible in
the background this same piece of
equipment showed up in infinity war in
the background behind Rhodey war machine
and Avengers HQ now we don't know what
this thing is but it could be some kind
of weapon and maybe this is just what it
looks like when it charges up another
theory is that this image could be
showing us the arrival of a new
character one ideas that could be
showing the space capsule that Captain
Marvel used to return to Earth remember
in the Captain Marvel trailer we saw
some escape pod looking shuttle has
sinned in Earth's atmosphere leading to
Carol Danvers crash landing in a
blockbuster or maybe we're looking at a
new character we've seen even less of
some people were describing this image
as a glowing cocoon suggesting that this
could be Adam warlock
we saw Adam warlocks cocoon T's in the
post credits Seaver guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 he was a super weapon being
engineered by Aisha to get revenge
against the Guardians Adam warlock is a
major character from the Marvel Comics a
genetically perfect super being who
carries the soul stowed in his head the
way
does with the mine stone in the
cinematic universe he plays a major role
in defeating Thanos in the Infinity
Gauntlet comic series but I think Adam
warlock was more of a tease for
guardians of the galaxy volume three
than it was for Avengers 4 I just assume
James Gunn included that little detail
for his own vision of where he one of
the Guardians trilogy to go then a clue
for the Avengers movies which were being
written and developed by a totally
separate team of filmmakers
but I think all these image enhancements
might just be going too deep into it
he's I really don't think the Russo
brothers tweeted out this expecting the
sharpest Photoshop analysts to be the
first ones to figure out their Avengers
secret and this blue glow just looks
really familiar to me first I was
thinking it kind of looks like that blue
glow from within Captain America's
capsule remember the one that he
transformed inside of maybe turn the
image sideways it kind of looks like
that and I was thinking maybe this means
we're in store for some kind of reset
for Steve Rogers in the movie previously
have speculated a ton of different
time-travel related theories for
Avengers core and to me the most
interesting of them still involves caps
reality being restored back to the time
period that he belongs in actually just
go watch my video on that but ultimately
I think the closest match for the Russo
brothers images Iron Man's I the blue
glow from within Tony Stark's helmet as
it lights up like the Russo brothers are
celebrating their production wrapping
with a photo close-up of the I from Iron
Man it makes sense but that doesn't mean
the fun of this whole tweet down has to
stop because why would the Russo's tweet
this
Iron Man I what's the significance of it
this whole framing and extreme closeup
of a character's eye is actually a
recurring shot used by directors on a
lot of TV and film these days to me I
immediately recognized it as the opening
and closing shot of the TV series lost
that show's pilot episode began with the
opening shot of Jack Shepards eye
snapping open in the final episodes
final shot return Jack to the same spot
with a close-up showing his eye closing
so why is this important well as I
pointed out in past episodes lost
co-star Evangeline Lilly who plays hope
Van Dyne wasp has let slip and
interviews that shooting Avengers for
reminded her a lot of shooting later
seasons of lost
later seasons which by the way feature a
lot of trippy platon devices like time
travel and splitting into parallel
realities perhaps what we're seeing here
is some similar shot composition by the
Russos the eye of Iron Man seconds
before the light flickers out so the way
Chris Evans tweets suggested captain
I died in Avengers 4 sacrificing his
life to save others I think it's
possible that looking back we may
connect this close-up of iron man's eye
to a key moment when Tony Stark does the
same coming down below with your
thoughts in this theory and follow me on
twitter and instagram @ ee vas and
subscribe the new rock stars moreover
thinking of everything Marvel related
and wait a minute that's not Iron Man's
I I've seen them before somewhere else
so let's zoom out oh my god it was
something Cheetos napkin the whole time
I knew it I tore it up but everywhere
the scraps what you use it why didn't
you eat barbecue ribs
[Music]